a local man says he still can't get his
car back from a Henderson mechanic now
we first told you about reported issues
with Dwayne's Automotive that was back
in November now several others came
forward with similar stories an
investigation is now underway but his
car still hasn't been recovered Sasha
Loftus joins us live in Henderson
tonight with an update Sasha
Denise and Brian that man I spoke with
calls this process just a never-ending
nightmare while some action is being
taken now he says he still hasn't seen
his car in 15 months
nothing has changed it's been two months
since we first introduced you to Aaron
schlifka when he disappeared so did my
car he was trying to get his car back
from this Henderson mechanic
that's unfortunately still the case
dropped it off thinking everything is
going to go fine and it's just been a
nightmare ever since he originally took
it to Dwayne's Automotive in November of
2021 and paid a part of the money up
front for a new engine but that was the
last time Aaron saw his 2018 Hyundai
that he's still making payments on WE
contact our insurance company
they say they can't do anything so we we
still have to continue to pay everything
after all
Aaron other authors reached out to 8
news now dealing with a Muller
situations
Nevada DMV compliance enforcement
division said there's now a stop on the
garage's business license and they're
actively working on recovering cars and
hopefully there's you know something's
going to happen where you know put this
put this guy out where you know he can't
do this to anybody else Aaron's
Sprint to get back what's rightfully his
get it over with give us our stuff back
let's move on
now the DMV says that stop on the
license here at Duane's means they can
no longer accept new customers but we
have spoken to other people who say that
they still haven't gotten their cars
back and those who have gotten them back
from this garage say they still needed
repairs reporting live in Henderson
tonight social Loftus 8 News Now